it is a rare insight into a critical
operation u.s. Delta forces move in on a
compound in northern Syria hiding inside
is the leader of the so-called Islamic
state Abu Bakr al-baghdadi US forces
discovered Baghdady hiding in a tone
when capture at the hands of US forces
was imminent Baghdady
detonated a bomb he wore killing himself
and two young children that were with
him back daddy who helped build a
terrorist army was also killed alongside
five other I asked others four women and
one next drone missile strike destroying
everything in sight
only rubble now remains at a Medal of
Honor ceremony president Trump praised
the team behind the raid who quickly
confirm they have their target through
DNA he was hit hard the way he should
have been and I just want to say for all
of our military were very proud of you
that was something very special the
whole world is proud of you frankly so
thank you very much but it was this dog
that helped trace back daddy injured
after he was exposed to live electrical
cables the canine combat veteran is back
on duty
America's troubles in Syria they are far
from resolved we suspect they will try
some form of retribution attack you're
never going to be able to completely
stamp it out and in fact our definition
of long-term success against Isis and
other entities like Isis is not the
complete absence of that ideology but
rather its existence at a level where
local security forces wherever in the
world it exists can deal with it there's
no international connective tissue
there's no ability to attack our
homeland and local forces perhaps with
training in some assistance perhaps
without those things is going to be able
to suppress those entities as they go
forward we don't see a bloodless future
US troops are already on a new mission
securing oil fields
woody lien and Sky News Washington